well we've been trying to negotiate uh
particularly with the train operating
companies for ages now we got to a
situation on Sunday
evening with a company vetoed a proposal
that the com the companies were going to
make that was called The Rail delivery
group
and I've been waiting for the last two
or three days to go back to the table
with those companies and it's quite
clear now that the government has got no
interest in making a proposal or
allowing those companies to make a
proposal and it's also absolutely
absolutely clear that they have
torpedoed these talks we gave them three
weeks before the start of the first
phase of action and the companies the
senior Executives of the Railway had put
together a document that they wanted to
put to us they'd also put together a set
of pay scales that they wanted us to
consider and we would have done that as
we have with network rail which we've
put to a referendum but at the last
moment including last night around about
six o'clock the government decided that
they would not allow the railway
companies to make that offer and instead
of instructed them to prepare for the
strike action which is we we think is
really really uh unfortunate because
they've been making all these noises at
the transport select committee yesterday
that their facilitators and they they
would try and provide
uh for um negotiations but it's
absolutely clear that they're not
prepared to do that and in fact they've
sabotaged and sunk the negotiations just
as they were reaching the point of
conclusion I'm not sure that was Mark
Harper on the phone for you the
transport secretary but he says
he's not a negotiator it's not his job
to negotiate with you guys
well he's not facilitating they're
they're obstructing I can tell you uh
okay I meet with the most senior people
in the railway and I've I'm on the phone
to them constantly and they are telling
me they've got a document ready to go
which will be challenging for us there's
no doubt about that there's some demands
in there that we find difficult and
people know that we've been discussing
it all through the year about the
challenges that we've got to face up to
they've got a document ready to go
they've shown it to me and they've shown
it to my negotiators and the government
has stopped them putting that document
forward the chief Executives in the
railway know exactly what they've got to
do to make a compromise and demand
compromises off us that's what
negotiations about and Mark Harper is
blocking this I don't think it's him I
think it's the treasury and I think the
hand of Grant sheps is playing a role at
the moment because they share the
documents amongst the Departments and
somebody decided on Sunday night just at
the point of conclusion of these or you
know the next stage of these
negotiations that they had to put driver
on the operation back on table and into
the documents and no matter what you
think of it they know that we can never
accept that as a principle on the
railway and we've been fighting it for
the last six years in various companies
and it's been our policy for 40 years
that we will never accept driver only
operation on our Railway and nor will
driver's Union as lift they've told me
last night that they will never accept
these proposals so when you're in
negotiation you try to find out what the
other side can accept you try to find
out what they can't accept and then you
try and work around those things red
lines and the company is deliberately
throwing uh something that nobody can
accept onto the table when everyone in
our industry even the management the
executive level know that these
negotiations are stuck because of the
attitude of the government okay let's
cut to the chase are you saying that
this government is purposefully
scuppering any chance of a deal
absolutely that's exactly what I'm
saying they have torpedoed the
negotiations and they have told the
companies to take on the strikes because
of what you heard in the comments
yesterday from Richie sunac acting tough
he's given in to his back benches and
all sorts of things about planning
permissions and other issues so he's
going to try and make the rmt and the
other trade unions as bogeymen and all
the rest of it and they want this strike
action to go ahead when there are
solutions and possible solutions the
railway management Railway Executives
could put to us to try and get a
resolution and they are stopping that
from happening and if you had the chance
to meet some of those Railway executive
Executives in private that's exactly
what they would tell you but they're not
allowed to say it of course because
they're contracted to carry out the
government's wishes in terms of policy
and Industrial relations Mick do you
want to have a general strike
I don't want the general strike but I
think the way that everything is going
at the moment with the the suppression
of wages the stresses and strains that
many workers are suffering in the Health
Service and education I think the trade
unions have got to maximize their
leverage uh and it would be it would be
Daft if they didn't coordinate and
synchronize their action I don't think
there'll be a general strike in the way
that we traditionally look at it but I
think the unions will coordinate and
synchronize their power and their
influence so that they can get a better
deal for their people because this
country needs to change and I think the
country's ready for change we need a
fairer society that is based on a
greater distribution of wealth the super
rich are insulated in this country we've
got corruption that seems to be endemic
both on our Railways and in general
Society the way that business is being
conducted and the only people that are
losing out is the ordinary men and women
that are running this country and
creating the wealth and if you take
these strikes that are going ahead the
train operating companies will not lose
a penny because of the corrupt way the
system is set up okay and the businesses
will lose money all during that period
and my members will lose money and
there's a corruption that needs to be
addressed